always ready to help but I think that is
thing the thing in that awkwardness is
the fuel it's like we were talking about
about having imposter syndrome that I
don't think it ever goes away I thought
one day it would gonna it would go away
I'm more comfortable meeting famous
people now than I've ever been before
but I still feel full of [ __ ] I think
you always will and everybody that I've
ever talked to that's any good they all
say the same thing like they all kind of
feel like no one ever feels like they're
anything special and you always like if
they're any good they don't know and you
always ruthlessly self-critical and
trying to get better I mean I work with
big actors big big rock stars and the
big rock stars like one big rock star
once one time said to me I opened he
said is there anyone out there I said
like nineteen thousand people you smell
the wd-40 that's how they got the last
thousand people in are you kidding he
said I'm always worried that no one's
gonna show up I said when was that
ever been your problem he said we'll
never but who is this Aussie Jesus
Christ yeah who's just one of my
favorite people
Jesus he's another guy he's honest how
many people we're like in some Floridian
megaton and he goes out there the place
goes nuts this show is great of course
and I said you worry about people don't
show I'll get really depressed about
okay
and you know I did the Beacon Theater
once many years ago in New York
beautiful room loved that place
I was I was a few days later I was at
MTV doing something with like Matt
Pinfield or somebody I was living in New
York and I'm leaving and the courtesy
lady she said hey George Carlin is in
the greenroom and he wants to meet you I
went wait a minute dumb question the
George Carlin because I've been
listening to that guy since I was in
eighth grade class clown and occupation
fool actually came out for me to go to
the record store they were not nice
price records they were what was on
that's how old I am
memorized in my eighth grade of course
and I said George Carlin wants to meet
me okay walk in and there's George
Carlin he's there to promote his next
HBO thing and he's gonna do like like
multiple nights at the Beacon Theater
place I would never sell out he was
gonna do a monk there or whatever and he
said ham I said mr. Carlisle I'm George
I'm like wow he said oh you did a book
signing the other night at Tower Records
I said yeah his aw man was so close in
line for like a half an hour and finally
I got so cold I went home I said you
waited in line to meet me like yeah I'm
like why don't you just walk in like oh
I can't do that man and and he said so
you just worth the beacon I said yeah I
was amazing he said did they get the
jokes I said oh okay I'm not that's not
really what I do I said I'm sorry what
do you mean he goes like did did can you
get to the audience from that stage I
said it's actually a pretty big place
it's a lot of feet before the first row
I said yeah I said you're George Carlin
I think you're gonna do okay but he was
sincerely wondering like is it gonna be
okay in there I'm like are you kidding
you were handcuffed with Lenny Bruce in
the back of a cop car and you're asking
me if it's gonna be okay yeah it's a
great book it's in that great book
ladies and gentlemen Lenny Bruce it's a
great read that's a read and a half I
read it not twenty two years ago I was
fantastic there was a time when the you
know as you know the First Amendment was
not being used in Lenny Bruce's life
towards the end of his life and that was
just every stand-up thing he did was
about the law towards the end and he was
in doing a show one night George Carlin
was there underage and George said
something and they were waiting they
pounced on him and then they went
through the crowd ID ID ID
oh come here youngster and they
handcuffed them together so I said and
that's how you met Lenny Bruce right he
said no I had met him before but he said
like we were literally one pair of
handcuffs together just like the book
but I thought that's that's not how we
met I said so how did you guys meet he
said Lenny Bruce was very sympathetic to
young comics so what we would do is like
he said give me
best five minutes and he would critique
us I said is he trying to take your
material no no he just he said like okay
leave that part out that part sucks do
more of that and that first part put it
last you would like help he said he was
great with all the young comics he said
like give me your stuff okay here's how
you redo it make it better I said so you
had known him before he said yeah I said
well because you know Lenny Bruce to me
is a real getting a hero an inspiration
fought back and um I I walked out of
there into like you know the freezing
you know he's New York to take the end
of the are back down to the East Village
like I but the fact that here's this guy
the point I'm making is stone-cold Pro
anywhere where I sell out half the
tickets he does 20 nights there yeah I
mean yo you'll never get out of that
shadow and even he is saying hey I have
a question yeah and here's what I found
with all of your big actors and big the
ones the ones I've worked with they are
obedient to the muse they work for the
art they are so subservient to the job
it's not about hey I'm rich I'm popular
it's like dammit I got to make this
script come to life right and they fear
it like someone on their first job and
there might have been a middle period
like in the 70s they had their idiot
phase for three years and they kind of
went sideways but man the big actors
I've worked with they're just so like
okay this take is everything and it's a
good lesson you're like okay never lose
that yeah